yeah it's good
so i'm glad to see it's bothering you
too yeah
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we return to my alma mater the
university of illinois for a hot one
special with illini basketball coach
brad underwood he's the man we're
crediting and trusting with returning
illinois to its former glory coming off
a season that included 16 conference
wins a big ten tournament championship
my coach brad underwood welcome to the
show sean welcome back it's great to
have you back on campus it's great to be
here and you know this is the first time
that we've ever done anything like that
and it's because the team last year i
liked many illini fans we fell in love
with that team and that's what led to
this homecoming of sorts but enough sort
of a puffy small talk let's let's break
it down to brass tacks how are you
around the spicy stuff good i i like hot
i like you know it's it's
i don't know what my tipping point is
yet but uh i got a feeling we're gonna
find that out but uh i tend to migrate
to hot
and uh we'll go from there
[Music]
okay
[Music]
fair
fair i like it
[Music]
i'm gonna lick my fingers
really just
marinating that one
[Music]
so an important part of your coaching
journey is the wild maze that it took
for you to get here working as an
assistant coach for 26 years before
getting your first head coaching job
from math tutor to travel agent what are
some of the more bizarre duties as
assigned things you had to do outside of
your job description working as an
assistant coach you know really my first
my first coaching job
was as the head women's cross country
coach
now if you know anything about me i hate
distance running i wasn't any good at it
i never did it
and yet here i am uh as a graduate
assistant
coaching basketball but i'm a head
division one cross country coach
and when you're a junior college coach
everything from doing the laundry
sweeping the floor every day before
practice
i was literally kind of a jack of all
trades uh handing out five dollars to go
to mcdonald's for your happy meal after
the game we did it all so it's it's it's
all part of the journey
and then i'm sure that they all had
their role but reflecting on that time
when you're working at junior colleges
and mid majors is there one stop on that
six state nine university trek that you
think disproportionately impacted or
shaped the coach that you are today yeah
you know i think at western illinois i
spent 10 years there
it's why i sit here today because i
realized how good a job the illinois job
was
while i was at western but
we didn't have a ton of staff
i was it and and then we hired one other
coach along with and and along with our
head coach so
uh you learned everything uh i traveled
a great deal i learned to recruit
uh scout and and you know i cut my teeth
uh really in the profession there
[Music]
could smell the difference
definitely a uh
step up
right
typically we'll do the 10-wing gauntlet
but but today you know it's a steep ramp
up for the special with coach underwood
you know i've got a feeling we're uh
by the by the looks at it i got a
feeling we're getting hotter quicker no
doubt that's what's happening
so i want to take this wing to get
granular about the x's and o's and full
disclosure i got a little help coming up
with these questions from one of my best
friends coach c who heads up the girls
varsity program at glenbrook north
you need a bucket at the end of the half
what is your internal calculus generally
the things that you're thinking about
when writing up a perfect sideline play
yeah i think first of all time and score
who's the match-ups who does the other
team have and who do they have guarding
the guy that i would like to get going
you know so we've practiced that we know
hey we're going to run this this and
this
uh and we're going to run it to that guy
and it really happens about that quick
do you have a guiding philosophy when it
comes to working the refs or is that
kind of communication just pure visceral
instinct and emotion
we see our officials a lot
so we know how they call a game uh you
know i think that there's certain guys
that we say oh no we've got them on the
road we're in trouble you know they're
homers
you know you're fighting you're grinding
and so emotion can be a part of it we
know who the officials are we study them
a little bit but we we uh
we try to give them the the benefit of
the doubt on most nights
and then i know that you have to rifle
through decades of experience and games
but is there a trick play that's maybe
the most memorable or one that you're
most proud of that you pulled off in a
meaningful game
i don't know if it was a meaningful game
i that would be uh
because it was not but we did the uh we
did the doc
the barking dog trick
we lined up on a baseline out of bounds
play three guys across in front of the
ball and a guy standing right behind him
and all three guys drop down on their
knees start barking like a dog everybody
looks down we throw the ball to the guy
and we lay it in so
unfortunately in the big ten play we
don't get a lot of the parking dog might
not work yeah it's probably not going to
work i don't think is is going to let
that one fly at in east lansing or matt
in west lafayette but uh you know i
think the one thing we try to do is is
be as creative as we can we've got a
full court baseline out of bounds which
got a lot of attention last year because
we stood everybody out of bounds as
they're pressing us and just stepped in
and caught the ball right and you know
so we try to do a little uh you know try
to be a little creative on that side of
things as well then finally what is it
that you find sacred about the spread
offense
to me it's the ultimate team-based
offense
it gets everybody involved you know in a
perfect world you want five six guys
averaging double figures that's that's
easy to do in that offense because
everybody gets involved you can take an
average player on the offensive side and
he becomes a threat because he can cut
and make a layup it's a team game we've
led the country and assists running it
that part of it's pretty special
a little kick in that one
we're progressing at a nice rate yep
accelerating quickly
and i'd get that one and i'd get that in
the restaurant that's good
wow i like that
yeah and that's a that's a powerful
sauce right there yeah that's pretty
good coach underwood i'm impressed i
gotta i gotta remember the name of that
i didn't know that was a pepper to be
honest
i've got i have a friend chili closs i
gotta i gotta introduce you guys so
he'll teach everything you need to know
that's good
my my uh i got a little like a little
after after taste yeah yeah it grows a
little bit
so one of my all-time favorite illini
players georgie bijan zvili he described
the rebuild as a beautiful struggle what
sorts of things do sports talk radio
hosts or die hard fans what are the
things that they maybe don't fully
understand or appreciate watching their
team through redefining through a
rebuild
that's so hard because we live in a
microwave society everybody wants to win
right now and there's no
shortcuts to success into winning and
and the one thing we've tried to do here
is lay an unbelievable foundation
uh
great character in our program great
guys
but along that way there's going to be
some speed bumps you have to not be
afraid to handle them and try to never
divert from where you want to go
there's no substitute for success and i
believe that's laying a great foundation
and working really hard maybe i'm
fishing for a game or a moment here but
at what point in the rebuild did it
start to bear fruit like at what point
did it become fun again in the locker
room yeah michigan state
game here
year two we had nine new guys sean we
were we were a young team we'd had a
really tough start to the season
ayo dasumu hits a shot from the top of
the key didn't have anything to do with
coaching it was kind of a broken play
and he just jumps up and makes it all
the stands empty there's people on the
floor so they got to have fun winning
they got to enjoy that moment and see
all the hard work paid off and there was
a reward for it at the end that that was
the one moment that
changed this thing
[Music]
that's no joke that one definitely gets
your attention
we'll have a sweat going here in just a
minute
that's what the people came to see
we're cleaning that wing
oh
i don't know if i would eat a second one
of those yeah yeah maybe this is it's
good for today but
wow
we'll take the bottle back with us yeah
that's that's a good good idea
oh
what do you see is the biggest
difference in
the selling points that would persuade a
recruit in the 80s and 90s versus today
[Music]
not to eat that hot
no i think the one thing is you know
when at 86 we had no three-point line
we had we had no shot clock
oh
take another little sip of milk on that
one
you and me both
you know back in the day there was four
corners offense dean smith there were
certain ways to win a lot of teams
played more zone
great aftertaste on that one
and then we live in the age of analytics
can you give me a metric that when you
first started redefining the program
here something that stood out to you and
then how did you go about reversing the
trend
[Music]
um yeah i think there i think there's a
couple points um
you know when i first came to illinois
you know we played a pressure style
defense and and
it was it was very very aggressive and
the one thing that happened was
uh we fouled a lot we were 333rd my
first year and fouls committed we
changed and the next year we were 13th
in the country in that stat
so you know i think we're always
evaluating how we
how we play what we do is there a better
way to do it
so it's it's just a great tool to use
all right coach underwood
oh boy
you don't have to if you don't want to
well i'm not going to let you do it and
be called soft so
i had a feeling that was coming
a dab or
yeah i kind of went a little crazy but
don't don't do what i did but that looks
good
let's go let's go
[Music]
yeah it's good
so i'm glad to see it's bothering you
too yeah listen we're both going through
it together we're sharing this
experience but thankfully coach
underwood
we've reached the end of our spicy meal
together it's the homecoming that i
always thought it would be the
homecoming that i always dreamed it
would be so with that in mind stephen
drop the curtain
awesome
awesome that's awesome
what does it mean after almost two years
of an empty arena from a coach's
perspective from a player's perspective
to once again fill this place up again
yeah that was the worst thing about last
year was our fans and they're passionate
15 500 in here
and and they didn't get experienced that
team and and see that personality and
how much fun they had together
that we can never get back but we've got
the best fans we're sitting here at half
court in an arena that is
uh is special when it's full it's going
to be full every night this year uh and
you're going to see guys with like kofi
guys like andre cabello and trent
frazier damonte williams guys that have
a lot of sweat equity and they play for
these colors the orange and blue seats
and and that's that's fun and our fans
understand that they're educated fans
uh and after being
gone
for a year it's so nice to to know
they're coming back
coach ill ini
thank you thank you
you crushed it
[Music]
there we go there you go nothing to it
nothing to it
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is sean evans checking in with a very
exciting announcement you know after 16
seasons i'd like to think that we
perfected the hot sauce symphony and now
i gotta hand it to us
we perfected the packaging it's the
custom-made hot ones official 10-pack
briefcase now available at heatness.com
take a look inside it's so pretty and
the perfect gift for the spice lord in
your life just get some friends make
some wings bring some ice cream and be
careful around the eyes heatness.com
heatness.com to get your hands on the
custom-made hot ones official 10-pack
briefcase
i know i love it
[Music]